welcome back to general julien podcast
episode is brought to you by thread up
the world's largest online thrift store
with up to ninety percent off retail
estimated price right now go to thread
up that's thre d u p calm / Jenna Julian
and get an extra 30 percent off your
first order start saving go to thread up
y'all also guys farmers dog a better way
to feed your dog's food that they
actually love even if you have picky
eaters right now go to the farmer's dog
calm /n and Julian get 50% off your
first two weeks and feed your dog some
real food that is delicious and they
will love salmon to prove salmon
approved
well how's everybody doing how are you
doing how are you doing how are you
doing are you asking the mic I'm asking
everybody in general how's everybody
doing
yeah let us know how you guys are doing
man I don't know this we were in an
unprecedented time right now nothing
like this has ever happened in any of
our lifetimes we are recording this on
March 15th day before releases as of
right now we're pretty much on a world
wide quarantine for lack of a better I
mean it's basically there right
everyone's we're hoping we're hoping
everyone is taking it seriously and
staying inside amidst this corona virus
that's going around and just putting a
whole pause on the entire world which is
crazy but we kind of just wanted to talk
and just have a conversation I don't
really even know like you know about
what I don't even have any things that I
you know need to say I just feel like we
should talk about this there's nothing
really else that I kind of feel like
doing in terms of a podcast well it
doesn't feel right it doesn't feel right
it doesn't feel right to make videos or
yeah I mean that's also that's the thing
that i sat with on wednesday because in
all honesty i haven't really left the
house and i think about
weeks no I stopped leaving the house
like a long time ago because I'm not
into it long before people started to
take it seriously well because I was
reading what was happening in Italy and
I you know like a lot of those people
pointed out in the article that at that
rate you know we're following this
similar rate and I was not I'm not a
person that's like I'm gonna wait until
the government tells me to stay inside
I'm like watch me stay inside watch me
beat I'm ready you were yeah and I think
I made some difficult decisions a little
earlier because well one of which was
deciding that I wasn't gonna go to my
friend's wedding which was hard and in
Texas because that's what next week it's
yeah this is coming weekend and I texted
her and I had a good cry and I felt
really guilty that I was canceling going
to her wedding and um you know she was
like it's everything's fine who gets
married during a pandemic which was a
funny sentence it's okay to laugh you
know it's okay to like try and stay
positive um then a few days later she
was like you know I think you're a
little early on this but we're thinking
about postponing the entire wedding
they're definitely gonna do it yeah and
it was that Tuesday that you texted her
yeah and um when I made my video on
Wednesday i sat down with Julianne and I
was like cuz at that point I was like I
don't even want to go to the store and
get bubble solution and you just ran
over there too yeah and that was the
last public environment I was in which
was Wednesday I went and bought the
bubble things in the wet and the
racquets and that that was it then I
came right home yeah and I sat down to
edit it and I was like is this even
appropriate like should I be posting
anything should I you know make content
right now is this insensitive you know
because I've been making content on
YouTube for 10
and we've definitely seen you know
tragedies that have happened where it
does feel really insensitive to post
content and it does feel like well what
the [ __ ] is this
you know this horrible thing happened
and you're just over here posting your
your stupid [ __ ] like thank you yeah and
something about this feels the same but
also feels a little different because
this is not like a tragedy you know like
a shooting something where you know your
life doesn't matter right now you know
it feels a little like somehow this is
our role in society is to be a little
entertainers kind of in theory in our
own way I didn't ask for that I guess in
theory I sorta fell into this and but
like it is okay during a time when
everybody's sort of going through the
same thing I mean not exactly the same
people are experienced this must much
worse than we are mm-hm and we're very
fortunate for that but that it is okay
sometimes to to just do your job
yeah well provided it's not putting
people at risk or whatever yeah if if
we're here to keep your spirits up and
to have a good time and to make you
laugh like I know a lot of people use
our podcasts as like an hour to just
throw on in the background fall asleep
to to listen to all they're doing chores
or hanging out or just not you doing and
not feel alone because there's people
talking yeah although it you know we're
all experiencing the fear is a good word
of a global pandemic you know this is
this is what we're here to do yeah and I
hope that us posting is not something
that you would see as us being
insensitive to what's going on or that
we're not aware of it or that you were
ignoring it we're we're just trying to
do our jobs yeah
and I think that it serves for a good
purpose which is we can still try and
entertain each other and make each other
laugh because we're all inside doing
nothing yeah yeah I we go a hundred
percent agree with what you're saying
and I even went so far as to like post
something on Twitter before I put my
last video up because I've been getting
on a schedule where I film videos in
advance and then I have one of the pipe
and then you know so I'm like kind of a
week ahead and you know I had this this
st. Patrick's Day one and I was like I
was so excited to post this but now I'm
like I think I'm gonna post a little
early because I think the longer I wait
the more out of touch it feels and I
posted this thing and I was like hey I
understand how this is a weird time and
I really don't want to come off as like
you know not sensitive insensitive to
what's going on and you know act like
everything's fine because in the video
I'm like all cheery and everything's
great because this hadn't really turned
into what's what's happening now at the
point of recording and I was received
with a lot of people that were like
exactly what you said like you know we
need kind of distractions in content
more now than we wouldn't normally I'm
[ __ ] bored
give me some content yeah and I think I
think there's there's ways to do it you
know what I mean like like your video it
was it was a heartfelt happy fun goofy
experiment video where you blew bubbles
with your hair right and you you know
you didn't talk about any of the current
events but you also were just like this
is this kind of isolated experience that
you can come join me for and then go
back to reality and I think that's fine
I really do and I like after kind of
posting the video and seeing how people
received your video but I also think
that there's there's a way to do it
wrong and it's you have to be careful
you know like you have to be careful not
to just feel like okay well now since
you know everyone's watching videos
online and everyone's cooped up at home
like I can post whatever I want I could
say whatever I want because it's like
the bottom line is there's coping with
it and there's joking to make yourself
feel over there and then there's like
going too far disregard disrespect
making people feel like
you don't care or that your
responsibility irresponsibility
spreading bad and misinformation or
whatever so yeah I mean I do think like
I it is a weird position of being right
now we're most of the world I would say
most of the world I might be wrong with
us is kind of like not working right now
or if they are there they're doing like
[ __ ] from home right like people are
trying they're trying yeah but I mean
like you know especially people who work
at brick-and-mortar spots a lot of those
are shutting down and people just aren't
working or decreasing hours I mean
people's lives are changing changing now
yeah drastically and I think we are in
kind of that weird spot where
technically our business can conduct
itself as usual for the most part on
paper right like me we post our podcasts
we stream we post our videos we post our
podcast extreme we post videos were on
social media
that's not whatever so yeah I think with
that comes a sense of like
responsibility but also like you know I
I do I I just have at the hospital
you're saying because I I felt it so
strongly the other day I was like I
honestly should just go dark
I shouldn't post anything people are
gonna be pissed at me right but I feel
like you know as someone who also likes
to be entertained as much as we post on
the Internet I'm a person that goes to
the internet cuz I want to see something
funny yeah and after you spent your
[ __ ] third hour on Twitter and your
third power reading articles all right
show me a video of a dog like show me
something that's I just need a break
yeah you know and it's not that I am not
aware I am not actively trying to
pretend it's not happening
mm-hmm I just need something else to
make me feel like in this moment right
now something's okay you know because
it's easy to snowball and become very
afraid and start doing things that don't
make any sense and we're fortunate that
in our lifetime you know we haven't had
to have something like this hmm
but you know when our parents and
grandparents and great-grandparents like
they they went through some [ __ ] man
where I'm like I haven't had anything
like that grandpa hmm
you will [ __ ] you a beast my guy
Yahoo
and we're facing something now and so
now it's time to be logical use our
heads
be smart stay calm I think you know I
watch a lot of NASA videos right NASA
anything that I do I do know that you
are smashing one of my favorite parts
about astronaut stuff hmm is when
horrific things are happening you hear
the audio from these people and they are
the most calm level-headed they make
decisions that are the best that they
can in the moment they execute them and
it's always amazing yeah I mean don't
give you high sometimes there's tragedy
in space yeah but what is very
impressive is when people stay calm
and they use their head during moments
of distress yes so I do think that
everyone's reaction however they're
feeling right now you're allowed to feel
your feelings and feel your fear your
anxiety where for maybe people like me I
feel happy here's a positive I feel
incredibly happy that I get to have you
home with me every day and we get to
spend time together I've been so happy
to do that some of the more positive
things have been when we cook together
and we can figure out new fun recipes to
make from the stuff in our pantry right
now because we're not going to the
grocery store you know what I'm saying
yeah fun things like that and I also am
a person that grew up in a place where
you go grocery shopping every two to
three weeks because it's [ __ ] snowy
outside and we got a winter ahead of us
you can't go outside there's a blizzard
stay in your room and entertain yourself
so I'm ready you know what I'm saying
[Music]
yeah yeah I mean it's weird man it's
weird like I've been finding both
watching things and consuming content is
a good escape but also like I've been
streaming a lot this last week because I
kind of just feel like the interaction
with people helps mm-hm like just
talking to people talking to you guys is
is a nice escape because
you're just kind of you're simulating
sort of a social environment a little
bit and like that need for for
interaction that you're not getting
right now and not only are you not
getting it but you know you're not going
to get it anytime soon right so it's
sort of like this anticipation of the
unknown I've never had to do this I've
never had you know pretty much society
come to a pause and everyone stay at
home that's a very new thing for all of
us and it's sometimes the more you think
about it the more it just kind of
spirals in your head and you get that
anxiety and you're like oh it's [ __ ]
freaking me out you know so like just
having outlets to talk to your friends
like FaceTime is a [ __ ] incredible
tool we live in a great time right now
like I face time my mom my dad my
friends it's nice it's amazing I make in
a way it's sort of bringing us all
closer together because we are so
connected mm-hmm and I've spent more
time you know talking to my mom more
like feeling closer to people because of
what's going on yes we are still
socially connected just not in person
yeah it's interesting it is yeah I find
yourself talking to your mom a little
more your dad a little reserved yeah a
little more my mom is not upset about it
yeah no definitely it's kind of nice it
is yeah and like you know thank God for
the Internet right well think of I was
reading a Twitter the other day how
Shakespeare was in quarantine you know
for a plague I forget which one mm-hmm
but you know one of the really terrible
ones that swept through Europe and he
wrote King Lear while he was in
quarantine but that he didn't have
Netflix my god I know you know what I'm
saying now he couldn't procrastinate
that right my guy was my guy row King
Lear and I'm over here farming mats in
the elder scrolls so you know yeah what
can I say I did watch an interview of
someone who was in Wuhan and he was
recovering mm-hmm
in quarantine and he said I think it was
he had been in there for eight weeks
which that Joe Rogan
Podcast was really good with the
infectious disease expert whatever his
name was or he was saying that you know
we really should be treating this a
little not like a blizzard and more like
a winter mm-hmm and you know being
prepared to social distance for a little
bit longer than people are thinking yeah
and um this guy was saying that he likes
to keep his mind busy by learning new
languages while he was there and I was
like oh no I just feel like a piece of
[ __ ] man not only got sick he recovered
you know he's dealing with this all
around him you know things are scary and
hard and he's learning a new language
and I'm over here just [ __ ] being an
idiot but it's true I mean what a great
time to be a [ __ ] gamer dude it's an
incredible tool it is a good distraction
you can I mean it's you can escape you
can you can just burn hours well let me
tell you I'm having a great time on the
other scrolls because it is populated
there's plenty of people to play with
everybody's on everyone's on everyone's
having a good time and we're all just
there to like laugh and be happy happy
yeah ten and I do want to empathize with
those of you out there who might be
going through situations were you may
not be directly affected with the virus
or your family might not be directly
infected with a virus but you're dealing
with problematic situations with your
families you know because a lot of
people go through things where you might
have a clear-headed ability to make you
know decisions in a time like this where
you're like okay I'm not going to go in
social situations I'm not going to go as
normal as everyone is is acting like it
still is I'm not gonna go to the bar I'm
not gonna whatever you can't come over
you know things like that where you feel
confident those decisions which by the
way you should feel confident those
decisions even if people look at you
like you're crazy social distancing and
quarantining is not it's not a joke I
mean it's like the whole idea is you
want to break the chain flatten the car
the curve and we need we we need
participation for that to happen and
that's what we have control and that's
what you every human being has control
over and so I want to empathize the
people whose families specifically like
elder you know their parents our
grandparents their older family members
who might be like minimizing that and
making you feel like you're crazy or
stupid or or what you're doing is is
over-the-top and and then turning it
into a personal situation because I know
that as hard as all of this is it's 50
times harder with family complications
like that involved and you know yeah
there's a million guys out there online
for how to social distance and how to
hand sanitize and how to practice good
hygiene but there's not a lot of guides
on how to deal with situations where
your family's like mad at you for trying
to follow the rules and make a
difference here so just know that it's
temporary and it you know it is the
right thing to to follow the rules here
into to be a part of you know making
this thing go away and not acting like
it's not here because that doesn't do
anything but worsen it and slow it down
slow us down and beating it so I don't
know I just I feel bad because I know a
lot of people like every family has
problems every family has their own
dynamics that are tough but this is one
of those situations where all of that is
exacerbated and I really you know I
can't I can't stress enough that like
just believe in yourself you don't I
mean believe in the decisions you're
making despite that that complicated
dynamic I don't know well I mean that's
one thing that makes it hard and another
thing that makes it hard is a lot of
people that want to work or need to work
right now and cannot yeah and there's
it's just incredibly difficult when
people need to afford their medications
and I'm not here to talk about anything
political and I don't want to get into
it but I I feel for you and I think that
as a community because I don't really
think our leadership is doing much to
help us on a personal scale for when it
comes to people that need life-saving
medications and that kind of thing I'm
hoping that as time goes by we can find
a way to help each other and our
communities right now yeah and soon
for those people that need help you know
because they they cannot take three
weeks off of work and be able to pay
their student loans their mortgage their
medication their bills whatever it is
and that some of those organizations
that you pay those things to would be a
little lenient in a time like this
mm-hmm so we feel for everybody
yeah we feel for a lot of you yeah and
in the most tasteful segue I could ever
possibly do if you want to save some
money and try to thrift shop online
within the safety and comfort of your
own home you can do so with thredUP
it's an online thrift store which
luckily like I don't know like so many
of our sponsors our online base and they
ship to your house okay but when you
quarantine and it literally is perfect
when your quarantine but if you do want
to shop for some you know really nice
clothing of the brands that you like but
hate paying the price for you go to
thread up and you can get up to 90
percent off estimated retail prices you
can get your designer clothings your
clothing in your favorite tops and new
bottoms and your socks and your shoes
and all the things that you desire but
for for cheap the dress up party in your
house you can have a fashion show in the
kitchen it's courtesy of thredUP
you could do it yeah I'm throwing up as
an online thrift shop and it's great
because it encourages choosing used
clothing over noon right if everyone in
the u.s. bought one used items that I
knew it would save nearly 6 billion
pounds of carbon emissions you can shop
more sustainably by thrifting and do it
on the comfort of your own couch and
thread it makes it really easy so you
get the great deals associated with
thrifting but the convenience of doing
it on your butt on your couch you know
yeah you can score some nike for six
bucks theory for like 20 bucks and lulu
for 27 I mean these savings are insane
especially because I mean not even in
the copy here but like a lot of these
stores aren't doing business right now
so you're getting you know an
opportunity to get some clothes here and
a tough time so go to thredUP that's th
our edu P comm slash Jenna Julianne
and you can extra 30% of your first
order you can filter by your size I find
the stuff that fits you right it's also
a good idea maybe to like have some
clothing you know reserved that maybe
you have a light wardrobe and this is a
time when you're like maybe I should
[ __ ] get some stuff just to have I
don't know so check it out or click the
link below also guys if you are looking
to get your dog some food that they will
love if your dog is a picky eater if you
want your dog to have a healthier diet
try farmer's dog farmer's dog is an
awesome farm-to-table
food service that brings the healthiest
food to your dogs right to your dog bowl
from their warehouse and for where they
make it right to your front door in a
box with what does it call the dry ice
where it keeps it nice and cold and
fresh it's beautiful
they provide human grade and people
tested recipes developed by board
certified veterinary nutritionists so
you know your dog is getting the right
food marble we all know he was a very
picky eater at one point he wouldn't eat
his dinner his breakfast mommy had to
sit right next to him when we brought
farmers log into the mix he runs to the
kitchen now at a speed that we don't
even know is not possible we can't
comprehend how fast he runs he's faster
than a Greyhound when he sees farmer's
dogs don't look that up also guys you
get 50% off your first two week trial of
fresh healthy food for your dog at the
farmer's dog calm slashed chin and
Julian check it out hit the link down
below to get started I think your pets
will be very happy with it's just a
little blur can't assume well he looks
like the sound barrier he's a sonic boom
but they're like sonic booms every
single step but his it's his tiny feet
that moves so fast it's like bunny runs
faster but his feet back and forth like
the amount of strides per foot insane he
has like a dust trail behind him
you want to know another thing I'm
excited about what are you excited about
even though it's a weird time to be
excited about anything I feel like right
now I have a little extra time since
we're staying in the house and not going
anywhere
so maybe do some of my laundry you yeah
that's a good shoe that's a good point
I love laundry and I just been letting
it get bigger and bigger and then
putting it off nice
we actually like home home improvement
and like cleaning up around the house
it's a good time for that I can finally
go through probably that's in your house
real like yeah maybe I'll organize that
one day yeah now is the one day yep now
is the one day I was the one day where
we go through and do all the things
we've been putting off yeah it's not the
worst thing nor it isn't the worst thing
in the world and uh yeah I mean I you
know back to the food thing we have we
have I'm proud of how much we've stocked
up we have some good stuff we have a
good amount of food we feel like our
pantry is solid we didn't panic by
either no this is something that we've
worked on ever since the brush fires and
the earthquakes we Julian as you know
he's done on his channel like a bunch of
times when you're prepping stuff
Julian's been prepping for a while and
so a lot of our stock is like dry rice
and beans and oats and stuff like that
mm-hmm
I mean what we don't have is a lot of
like produce so hopefully we're kind of
living on Mars my neighbors will give us
some of those delicious lives of
jalapenos they'd be growing it that's
true that's true we got the plug I love
them bring this like jalapenos in
sometimes I'll just put it in a baggie
leave it at our front door and we're
just like we love you someone love but
yeah I mean I'm honestly I'm pretty
proud of the amount of supplies both
with food and also others that we have
mass over the last like year for just
general preparedness for general
preparedness I mean I you know I like
I'm kind of a like a prepper in that way
I'm not like it's not a hobby but I like
to have things I like to have a go bag -
yeah it's not apocalyptic you know it's
reasonable realistic like something
could happen and we should be ready yeah
with like extra dog food extra dog food
extra stuff like that batteries
flashlights clothing tarps tape yeah and
then um yeah and so actually what I was
what I was considering doing it and I'm
undecided on this but I was considering
if I do a cooking video anytime soon I
think it might be fun to do a video
where we try to just like make do with
what an everyday pantry would have like
dry goods that are in people's pantries
well I made with them a cool thing that
you could do which I've always wanted to
do with you and for you is because a lot
of the bread that we buy in a grocery
store anyways if it's gluten free a lot
of times contains eggs I know this is
very nation doesn't apply to a lot of
you but it contains eggs so we go way
out of the way sometimes to go to the
sprouts to get the one kind of bread
little mouse baby and its really good
but I've always wanted to at home make
our own loafs of bread know that you
know we could tweak it and work on the
formula a little bit so you've got a
type of bread that was really great and
it's also I know there's a lot of people
that love making their own homemade
bread but not a lot of people just
everyday are like oh I just made some
fresh baked bread for everybody yeah my
mom would well people who love to cook
yeah definitely I think that would be a
fun thing I thought like trying to make
some bread when you're at home and you
have flour and you maybe have yeast
mm-hmm or maybe that's something you
would need to get but like look how less
I'm I'm having to go get bread cuz I
just squished it in my car cuz I just
okay I made I think making a loaf of
bread would be a fun thing think of all
the delicious nut butters you could
spread on your bed when I think of bread
though I just think of straight-up
butter does that make me white trash
I just want butter on bread no no no
that's really like that when someone
said that's my bread bread and butter I
understand why that's saying caught on
because bread and butter let me tell you
for the first time in your life you're
now learning that bread and butter is
very good go try it
no I am garlic powder and I mean it's
really good
well the good thing about a loaf of
bread is you can have some of the loaf
and I can have some of the loaf so we
shared that loaf yeah but yeah I think
making bread would be fun I think that's
a good idea I think a lot of people
probably have flour
maybe east maybe salt oil whatever the
[ __ ] egg replacer I don't know whatever
you guys have um but yeah the idea was
like take things that don't go bad
really you know for a long time maybe
beans rice other things in your pantry
dude I could do some mad science I could
go in that pantry and I can grab some
crushed tomato some being some rice some
spices and be like what we gonna make I
don't know I don't know if I decide to
make a cooking video anytime soon I
might make a vlog I don't know what I'm
gonna do I'm also feel like like I said
earlier I was like I was on the schedule
or I was a week ahead with my videos and
I don't think that's a smart way to do
things right now because if I film a
video and I'm like alright this will go
up in a week
come seven days later things might be a
lot [ __ ] different yeah like things
were changing really fast every single
day there's new information it's just
it's hard so I don't mean I'm not
looking yeah well I'm I'm hopeful that
you guys understand what we're trying to
say and that like I'm I you know we
didn't think of anything beforehand
we're just honestly trying to speak from
the heart
yeah but that I understand my job in
this world right now is to sort of like
be here fans you know I'm I'm a clown
I'm the clown right yeah and it's like
in sports you have a team a necessary
part of a team is someone who is there
to lift the mood to laugh to do stuff
and that was me and a lot of times your
coach is like [ __ ] stop it but it
does serve a purpose yeah you know do
you need that person or something in
your life that's there to just lift your
spirits a little bit yeah and we're
gonna try our best to do it as
respectfully and sensitively as we can
but that we are here to try and either
give you a distraction or something you
know because I'm I'm I just couldn't tap
out because we scared
you know I'm trying to make words that
are coming out right but they keep
coming out weird no no I your point is
coming across I think very clearly like
you're aware of your role you're aware
of your strengths and you kind of feel a
responsibility to do that for people
right now without coming across
insensitive I do yeah I do feel a
responsibility yeah to to be like hey
guys we all in this together it's okay
to laugh it's okay to entertain yourself
it's okay to distract yourself stay calm
and I even last week when we were making
the video when we were talking about
what I wanted to do for my Wednesday
video I said you know I want to stay in
the house but if I'm being honest with
myself I do think that next week and the
week after in the week after you know
we're looking at situations where I
don't think I can go to a beauty supply
store and you know get something or I
don't think I can go to art store yeah
yeah so you know why don't I do
something this week and then maybe next
week or the week after we can watch some
tic TOCs we can do stuff where we're
just in the house you know and I don't
have to get go out into the world and
get supplies for that 100% agreed agreed
but we can do that we can do it here to
do it
need to do it to him do it to him and
I'm hoping that everyone continues to
practice good hygiene and social
distancing and we can flatten that curve
we can flatten the curve we can do what
we we need all of you guys to be
participating and I know we're not
really I'm not a doctor we're not really
people well know what I was gonna say is
we're not people who like to you know
tell you what to do ever a preacher
whatever we kind of just like we enjoy
having you guys here and come you know
have conversations with us in some
capacity all the time but if you're
looking for us to tell you what to do
here just follow the rules and social
distance and don't go out of your house
if you don't absolutely [ __ ] you have
to and if you do wear gloves and just be
as safe as you can I mean and treat this
like it's like the dangerous terrifying
thing that it is and remember that every
single person like you all have
of an equal role in in getting out of
this no no you know I mean like every
one person is capable of helping and
also hurting the situation yeah so just
treat it seriously and you know wash
your hands she's like don't be dumb
social distance yeah and I'm thinking of
you know we have a couple friends right
now that are pregnant you know some
friends with respiratory illnesses
autoimmune disorders and I just think of
them and I hope that it's like when
you're afraid of a pandemic right go out
you'd maybe take public transportation
you're out in the world I've washed my
hands and I'm trying not to
Koff on other people and you're looking
around you and you're thinking I hope
these people have washed their hands and
I hope that they're not sick and I hope
that they're not coughing at me you know
you know be the person that you are
hoping is around you yeah well said yeah
yeah and if you work if you are working
in healthcare right now if you're
working in hospitals or thank you thank
you so much and we applaud you and you
and your your service and your bravery
right now and yeah I mean [ __ ] I don't
know it's like it's hard like it
sometimes all I'll be away from the
internet for like two three hours or
whatever and then I'll like go back
online and I'll read a headline and I'm
like this is real this is still
happening this is actually and it just
it's bizarre is a bizarre time right now
well I mean it's not the first pandemic
and it will not be the last you know
yeah but we can improve the way that we
handle situations and I think it's I
mean it's exposing a lot mm-hmm
in terms of how we are capable of
handling a situation yeah like this
particularly in our country yeah and I
think I hope that it will contribute to
hearing that
bettering the future hundred-percent
yeah that's that's absolutely true and
it's a good way to look at it I mean
well it's definitely teaching a lot of
people a lot of different things right
now about how things work and when
things like this happen
what systems should already have been in
place but I do think it it helps to not
spiral and to stay calm and to stay
positive so hopefully we can try and
help those of you that come here for
that mm-hmm we're gonna try and help
keep that mm-hmm and one thing I would
say if I may like and I think we're past
this I like to think we're past this but
like less than a to two days ago like
within the last two days I remember
seeing posts from people sporadically
saying like flights are cheap or you
don't do that you know uh I'm young I
don't you know I can fight this off I'm
gonna go travel once in a lifetime like
the things like that I feel like not
only is that a bad decision for you to
make but it's a selfish one that you
might not be thinking of why it's
selfish because you're like oh I'm just
gonna go do this everyone else can deal
with no like you're if you are out in
the world right now you are actively
potentially worsening the situation and
especially if you don't need to be out
in the world and if specially if you're
doing travel that you don't need to be
doing I mean who really needs to be
traveling right now obviously there are
circumstances that I'm not thinking of
that our you know way more important but
like don't be a young kind of selfish
person
thinking hey I'm gonna go travel because
flights are cheaper now because I kid
you not like I've been seeing post like
that and it's upsetting and it's a
bummer and although we've been taking
this seriously for the last two three
weeks longer than that a lot of people
still aren't getting to that point and
it's it's a bummer so you know like I
said earlier with the family thing like
it goes the same way with people who are
your age appears if you know they're not
getting it try to help them get it
because it it's very important and you
don't want to tell people what to do but
in a situation like this you kind of you
have a responsibility to guide people in
the right way and we are people who have
an audience and that's why I'm saying it
because I feel like if you're one of
those people there's nothing wrong with
you it's just like try to really think
about your decisions right now that's
all you know yeah that's it that's all I
got follow the advice of medical
professionals mm-hmm and don't think
hoard hand sanitizers like that one dick
why did he do that why did he do that no
a bunch of people can't sanitize but
it's okay because you can wash your
hands if you're staying at home just
wash your [ __ ] well I have a whole
hand made out of soap oh my god that was
ahead of its time mm-hmm damn that smart
squirt doing work for us in the pandemic
thank you
I was saying thank you squirt you were
just kind of there squirt did all the
work also uh I don't know how your pets
are taking this but ours are doing a
good job channeling their inner
couch-potato loafs like they have
moments of crazy because we're not
walking them we're staying at home so
well we probably will eventually but for
the last few days we're just like fully
just in the house yeah well luckily we
are but if you don't like you know good
luck with your dogs I hope they're doing
okay sometimes no bunny is so happy
Julian because we usually go to the gym
you know we go to the grocery store you
know we do stuff like that on a daily
basis but she's used to you leaving the
house like two or three four times a day
and she is so happy that you were just
here she could not be happier because
Julian is her favorite person and she is
just like really really really what are
you doing
she is really opening up even more
because you've just been around this is
what she looks like right now on the
ground the whole time like half in her
bed half she's she is she's a she's a
full-blown puppy right now she's like
mommy and daddy are here all day long
all day long daddy never leaves this my
baby should tell them what she does in
the morning now we have top bunny
that in the morning when we wake up she
can come and have some bedtime with us
where she jumps on our bed on the foot
of the bed and it's very respectful of
all of our space me jenna kermit marbles
peach and says to the for the bed but
very very excitedly pause and asks for
pets and scratches and love yes oh she
does think we we originally you know
when we got her we're having her crated
at night with the crate shut with the
crate shut yes she was comfortable with
that she was very afraid of our bedroom
she was afraid of everything in there
and then you know she would cry so we
would open her crate door and then she
felt more comfortable and then she
started doing this thing where she'd get
up like right after you went to bed and
like walk around the room and I'm like
what are you doing like go to bed yeah
yeah so then we started putting beds
around the room just in case she ever
wanted to not sleep in here crazy yeah
no you tell us yeah so she would come
she would sit in her bed for a while
then she'd go to crane and she'd go back
but usually she'll eventually end up in
her crate overnight mm-hmm and then in
the morning we would hear her just
walking around the room like these you
know giant claws walking around yeah and
then she would give us kisses and like
wake us up and then we come up to the
side of her back she's horse height and
just kisses us while we're in bed so we
finally were like okay come get in the
bed we're going just for like some
mornings it's the best part of the day
she is in such a happy excited mood she
jumps up and she gives you so many
kisses and then she wants so many pets
and scratches she's just and then once
everything calmed down you're gonna like
check your phone and drink some water
she just like chills there at the foot
of the bed like a dog and then as soon
as you want to get up she's like alright
it's breakfast time Beach let's go yeah
but she she is very very well behaved
you were out of town a little while ago
and I was nervous that since there was
so much space in the bed now that you
weren't there that she you know she
looked for him I was so sweet she was
like smelling your side of the bed like
where are you like she kept checking to
see if you were there and I was nervous
that this was not a morning snuggle you
know that this was gonna turn into that
bed is really comfortable and I'm gonna
sit up there if I want yeah but she
didn't she slept in her crate while you
were gone and then did the same that you
came up only when I
start doing them she's very respectful I
thought it was gonna wake up and she was
gonna be sleeping next to me yeah no
that's the only way this works is what
if she respects the rules and she's done
a great job of like understanding when
and when not to come up on the bed well
that's been the easiest part about her
is that we haven't specifically trained
her to do a lot of things she's just a
respectful she's a respectful dog she
like she understands when we say don't
do something or do something and she
follows those rules tell me why we can
get away with having a baby gate that
doesn't even like actually attach to the
door and is like you know less than
chest height on her and she just
respects the boundary and never leaves
yeah like we baby gate the game room
when we're in there and we're streaming
for hours and assume that she stays in
there with us and that she doesn't go up
because although she likes to watch
Seinfeld alone sometimes she just gets
up at peace it's not a hundred percent
sure how to tell us yes but you're right
that gate is a joke even peach can get
past it and wash it and open it she
opens it with her nose like whenever she
wants bunny just stands there like okay
I guess I can't go this way like feet
disrespectful like usually follow the
rules okay yeah thank God for dogs yeah
anyways yeah we just wanted to talk for
a minute and hopefully you guys can let
us know like are you cool if we try our
best to keep the mood up yeah would you
like us to talk about things yeah what
would be helped what would be helpful
tell us yeah see you know like let us
know what what content would be helpful
for you guys in in general right now
during this time because we want to hear
and one thing that's been happening for
me lately a lot is in the last week I've
been live on like I told you I've been
streaming a lot more so I'm live if you
wanted to chat with me and hang out like
go to watch which channel because I'm
I've been doing that a lot and I think
that's kind of a nice thing I'm doing it
selfishly all admit it it's therapeutic
to talk to you guys yeah like I love it
so
but yeah let us know and hopefully all
of you guys are doing well and staying
safe and um we'll see you here same time
next week for another podcast hopefully
things will be a little bit better by
then right
yeah have a good week stay inside be
good
stay inside we'll see you guys in a week
maybe you learn the language not just
game
[Music]